Well, there's five boroughs and it feels almost impossible
to experience everything that the city has to offer,
but that doesn't stop us from trying one borough at a time.
(audience laughs)
I met up with my new bestie.
I am not kidding, Fat Joe.
(audience cheers)
Who's such a good human, oh my God.
I see why everybody worships him.
And he took me on a tour of his native borough, The Bronx!
Let's take a look.
(upbeat music)
Hey everyone, we're here in the Bronx
with the Grammy nominated musician, entrepreneur,
and Bronx native.
And he is about to take us on the ultimate Bronx tour.
I just can't wait to meet him,
and I'm actually going to meet him right now.
Welcome to the Bronx.
Fat Joe!
I think I'm going to record this show
and play that intro back every morning for motivation.
Where are we going first?
This is the number one Italian bakery
in the Bronx.
Let's go.
I'm so excited.
(upbeat music)
Oh wow.
There's cookies with our faces on it.
Shout out to the staff of Artuso.
Oh my god!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's the biggest cannoli-
That's called a CANNOLI!
Believe it or not.
They specialize in all desserts.
The favorite thing of mine here is birthday cakes.
Do we get to try the birthday cake?
Big time!
Oh my gosh. That is-
This is beautiful.
Home is where you are, wow.
You've been married 26 years.
26 Years.
Yeah, it's been real.
(laughs)
Joe give me a word of wisdom about longevity and merit.
When you meet the person you love,
a switch goes off where you say, this is it.
Cause I had no money.
When I met her, I lived in an apartment
and I only had a mattress.
And so we made the pass and said listen,
if we get successful,
we're never going to leave each other.
We're never going to change on each other.
Joe, there are so many things I want to keep talking
to you about.
Let's go to the next location,
and we'll pick another profound, dope subject.
This guy is amazing.
We're going to Jimmy spot's Con Sofrito
to give you that real authentic puerto.
You can't, you can't get realer in this.
(upbeat music)
[Fat Joe] Jimmy is a living legend.
He make these recipes and mix things up
that no one would ever think of in the Latin community.
Now this is sancocho.
All right.
It's a hardy soup.
It's got meat and starches and root vegetables.
I am so excited.
Okay, here we go you guys.
This is my very first bite.
Enjoy
(investigative music)
How does that taste?
Nah stop. C'mon.
It's good.
You got to stop Drew.
You know this is the best.
I've been collecting sneakers my whole life.
For 20 something years.
And so, we're about to go to my newest store
that hasn't even, we're going to reveal it on your show.
It's called Up NYC, the Bronx.
And let's get going over there.
Break out the clique lights.
We have a premier coming.
Let's go.
(Fat Joe laughs)
Wa lah! after you.
So this is the latest creation of Up NYC.
The third store, we're in the South Bronx.
We wanted to do something really,
really beautiful for the community.
You know, a lot of people who get successful,
whether they're famous or they're entrepreneurs,
the dream is to leave the hood.
And most of them never come back.
The thing that I liked is we create a hub,
a safe place for the community,
showing that the future entrepreneurs are successful.
People that come from the hood, you can be successful,
move out, but you could come back
and just give inspiration and give hope.
I am really like just insanely overly impressed.
Let me show you this room over here.
We have a learning center for kids
that don't have access to computers
that I'm going to have my successful friends
come once a month and give them a,
a motivational for the kids.
And the project's right across the street.
So let me show you Drew, so you can see that this is real.
(upbeat music)
[Fat Joe] This the projects.
Affordable housing across the street.
It's something that people take our community
serious and invest back and show them the love
that they need and the support they need.
What do you think attributes the most
to being such a good person?
I just think I been through so much in life
that we have no choice,
but God has blessed me and my family.
But to give back to my community and just offer them hope
or inspiration.
And I got something for you,
[Construction Worker] Is that Drew Barrymore?
Hi!
That's Drew Barrymore in the hood!
[Construction Worker] We love you!
Oh thank you! We love you too!
(Drew screams)
Nothing but love y'all.
These are some dunks called New York versus New York.
All the street basketball parks are down here.
It's just a gift from us to you, you know, up NYC,
you know?
Cause we love you and we thank you.
Appreciate you and all the love you're showing us.
This is such a big deal
that I'm going to get a pair of sneakers from you right now.
(Fat Joe laughs)
I mean, I just can't, it's like we're in England
and I'm being knighted by the Queen.
I mean, you definitely been knighted in the Bronx.
Thank you for literally making me
the coolest person amongst my friends.
What do you think?
Those are fly and they match!
What are you going to do?
Oh man.
(audience clapping)
Oh Joe, I love you so much!
I love you so much.
And uh, Fat Joe, he hooked us up with some cool sneakers.
So we thought we'd do the same for all of you.
I mean, I have sneakers from Fat Joe.
I have so much cred now, it's not even funny.
All right, so everyone in our studio audience
is going to get a pair of Vessi shoes.
(audience cheers)
What's really cool about these is they're 100% waterproof.
Ooh, that's sexy in this city,
(audience laughs)
and vegan which is also so good.
(audience cheers)
And also let's face facts.
I didn't wear these shoes on a borough tour.
If you're going to walk around New York,
do yourself a favor, wear something doable, comfortable,
and stylish and go to any neighborhood that you want
and enjoy yourself.
(upbeat music)